the bears are going to have a downfall
of their head coach and their gm if they
don't win they are considering upgrades
at quarterback there's a report now that
they have talked to the panthers about
quarterback cam newton and i'm also told
the chargers are having discussions
internally chris
but here's but here's the thing right no
one's trading for this guy right because
you can't let your doctor
look at ankle foot shoulder or anything
else that may be broken or impaired on
cam newton until the covet 19 outbreak
resolves to the point where people can
go back to work and where teams can have
players come to the facility to be
physically examined or doctors can go
and examine players and i look i think
that this is the next step of the
panthers effort to get someone to trade
for him putting it out there the bears
have talked to the panthers yeah maybe
they have and the bears have said well
you're crazy we can't do this i mean
they're gonna have to cut him i'm
convinced of it they're going to have to
cut him when you look at what marty
herney the gm of the team said yesterday
they've already tried to trade him
they've talked to teams they've gotten
nowhere so now they're giving permission
to cam to find his own trade
he's not going to find one it's not
happening especially in this climate
well okay all right there's a few things
first off you know they could they tried
to trade them
you know before
all this went down the last few days you
know i think a lot of teams are looking
at like we're going to get the guy we
want in free agency we don't have to
deal with cam newton in a trade in a new
contract yet well there's two teams that
got left out in the dark so now they're
reevaluating going damn we didn't get
jack diddly crap here so what do we do
and they're looking at it going okay
well man the carolina panthers have kind
of pinned themselves in a corner here
where we we know they're not staying
with cam newton they can't demand
anything like crazy trade wise i mean
they can't somebody will just go now
that's crazy right now the bears and the
chargers if they ask for a second round
pick they're just gonna that's crazy
forget it no way i mean maybe they can
get that i don't know you know but but
ultimately i hear what you're saying but
to me mike here's the thing that i just
like i mean if cam newton just goes i'm
getting on a private plane and i'm going
to see the doctor in chicago like what's
what's the nfl going to do are they
going to be like you can't you can't you
they're violating the rules if they have
that physical they're violating their so
what if cam what if cam newton
goes to a doctor that's not affiliated
with the bears but yet they sign off and
go okay we will trust this doctor's
opinion he's one of the well-known
doctors in our country and he's amazing
and he and goes and gets that physical
there
okay to where now they can sign off on
it or the chargers whoever it may be i
mean what are they going to do they
can't throw cam newton out of the league
right i mean so that's to me where if
they want to make this happen i think
they can make it happen and both of
those places make sense
the challenge is
cup it's twofold
uh number one the nfl is putting these
rules in place with the expectation the
rules will be followed and and this is a
you know a delicate time in our nation's
history where
it's going to be a horrible look if nfl
franchises deliberately break the rules
to gain an advantage later and and so
they're going to i look it
i think they deserve to be ripped by
everyone if they don't follow the rules
that everyone else is following and and
secondly i think they deserve to be
whacked by the league office if they get
caught with their hand in the cookie jar
doing something like this but the best
hope for the panthers is to
get two teams bears chargers right and
one of them is willing to say screw it
we'll send a sixth round pick we'll send
a conditional
fourth round pick in 2021 if cam newton
is on our week one roster right you get
creative that's one of the challenges
you've got the rules and you come up
with ways to operate within the confines
of the rules and something like that a
2021 draft pick
and maybe it goes as high as a second
round depending upon how many games he
plays if you're willing to tie up
multiple picks in that contingent
calculation
but
you want at a minimum the protection of
having him on the team so
yeah hey we'll do a trade for cam newton
but we're not given anything in this
draft we'll give it to you in next
year's draft if he's on the week one
roster i think there's some wisdom in
that and if you can get two teams
interested then that's when you spur
that conversation if only one team is
interested that team just sits back and
waits for cam newton to be cut i like
how we're talking this through here yeah
because there is a way to do it right
there is a way to get the panthers some
compensation if cam newton ultimately
checks out and passes a physical
implemented by a team doctor and the
team says okay he's going to be our
quarterback and if they cut him then uh
they cut him and the panthers don't get
anything yeah that's right i mean yeah
the panthers ultimate scenario is to
hope that the chargers and bears both
want him i think he really fits both
places that's the other thing too i mean
the chargers want to run the ball
anthony lynn he's the ex-running backs
coach he wants to play defense
i think he wants to control the ball on
the offensive side of the ball being
more efficient that way because they've
been a little careless with philip
rivers the last few years you know the
bears i mean that offense we know they
want to move the quarterback you know
right now you look at that all you know
they have a super bowl type defense at
chicago they don't have a lot of like
they have a lot of good on the offense
no great and cam newton i think can make
that good a lot greater he can make guys
like alan robinson and anthony miller
look like oh damn they're better than we
thought yeah of course they're better
than you thought when you got a guy
throwing lasers 25 yards down the field
that's hitting them in the face yeah
they're gonna be a lot better so i think
that could work too and you know you're
chicago you want to play defensive style
football control the clock have teams
come in there cam newton can do that
we've seen that he can run the ball
three plays in a row drop back to pass
on third down on third and ten and throw
a strike he's not one of those guys that
needs to be a rhythm passer and do that
way so
i think both those places make a lot of
sense and you've hit on the chargers i
mean we know why they need them
i've been saying from day one yeah
i got i had the feeling that that you
know they're going to have changes in
carolina and it's time to move on from
cam newton that's the guy the chargers
need to get that's the guy that will
sell tickets and it's not a one or
two-year thing if he's healthy he's
going to be there five six seven years
and really help that team establish the
foundation it needs to establish in los
angeles
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports